[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
stéphanie de la fosse et les chefs du
secteur des publics spécifiques
au château de versailles et j'ai à ma
droite laurence du pain qui elle est
présidente de l'association arc
convergence basée à plaisir et dont nous
avons déjà plusieurs fois parlé on s'est
déjà vu sur ce plateau laurence n'est ce
pas là pas si longtemps
voilà alors aujourd'hui ce qui nous
ramène ce qui nous rassemble c'est un
événement qui est à peine sorti de
l'oeuf parce que c'est en préparation
aujourd'hui on est le 9 septembre ça va
durer jusqu'au 19 septembre vous avez
organisé une exposition qui s'appelle
d'un commun accord et qui entre dans le
cadre d'un processus de création mis en
place par le château de versailles qui
t'appelle escale à versailles alors on
va en dire un petit peu plus d'abord
laurence art convergence pour ceux qui
ne seraient pas quelle est cette
association alors l'association art
convergence est une association qui a
pour objectif d'aider des personnes qui
ont des maladies psychiques à travers
des projets qui mettent en valeur leur
talent leur talent artistique plus
particulièrement il la plupart du temps
on les fait travailler des artistes
professionnels pour aboutir des
expositions c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois qu'on est au château de
versailles c'est un énorme un immense a
en fait je pense pour tous et pour les
artistes et des plus l'ensemble des
parties d'ailleurs vous avez eu des
expositions par exemple aux beaux arts
de versailles au château de saint
germain en laye pour ne citer que celles
ci voilà donc là pour l'instant on est
au château de versailles on n'est même
plus précisément dans l'orangerie
jussieu au coeur du domaine du trianon
oui tout à fait grâce à l'intervention
de 1,7 delafosse
alors stéphanie de la poste donc vous
votre travail en quoi consiste-t-il déjà
en quelques mots donc le secteur des
publics spécifiques on s'occupe du des
personnes en situation de handicap et
les personnes qu'on dit éloigné des
musées notre objectif comme on est un
établissement public et ces d'accueillir
et d'ouvrir le patrimoine à tous et donc
de faire venir ces publics qui sont
parfois un petit peu en difficulté pour
venir soit pour des questions physiques
ou parce qu'ils sont un peu éloignés de
du monde de la culture en fait quand
vous dites et loyers des musées c'est
géographiquement parlant ou pas
socialement oui avec l'environnement
voilà on a aussi des cavic empêcher tout
ce qui est public hospitalisés public
sous main de justice voilà tous ces
publics là c'est nous qui les gérons
également les accueille et on fait en
sorte qu'ils aient envie de revenir
aussi en plus voilà et alors c'est le
cas jusqu'à présent ça marche plutôt
bien
pour ce faire vous avez mis en place un
dispositif créatif que vous avez appelé
escale à versailles voile alors en quoi
consiste-t-il c'est un dispositif qui
est né en 2014 avait enfin on a
rencontré une association en fait qu'ils
travaillaient sur sur d'expression
artistique auprès des personnes en
situation de handicap et on a eu envie
de les accueillir au château et puis ça
a eu un beau succès et en fait on a eu
envie de poursuivre en fait ce
dispositif est donc ça un dispositif qui
a lieu tous les deux ans pour se laisser
le temps un peu de concevoir le projet
de rencontrer les bonnes associations et
bon partenaire pour pour monter ces
projets là et ensuite pour trait pour
laisser le temps aussi à la création
artistique des personnes en situation de
handicap etc une fois excusez moi je
recoupe une fois qu'on a le projet il
faut la création voilà il faut la
création il faut qu'on ait du temps donc
en fait ça se fait en construction avec
les artistes l'idée c'est leur faire
découvrir le patrimoine de leur faire
découvrir le château de versailles
premier lieu voilà en premier lieu et
ensuite de les amener à faire
à construire une création artistique
avec les artistes puis à les exposer
dans le domaine et ensuite on à
l'édition d'un petit album souvenir un
petit catalogue qui perlaient si par
hasard voilà donc on en a eu trois celui
là c'était la troisième édition d'accord
coiffé décoiffé là nous avons escale
dans les jardins de versailles c'était
la première édition et la belgique à la
trianon voilà tout à fait et il nous
manque d'un commun accord évidemment
puisque l'exposition est en devenir
incessamment sous peu exacte est on a un
dispositif un petit peu différent par
rapport aux précédentes les précédentes
c'est de chaque personne en fait créé sa
propre propres oeuvres et ici on est
dans une démarche plus collective
d'accord c'est une preuve de votre
association art convergence laurence ne
sera pas toujours mais là c'est vrai
qu'on est aussi adapté aux circonstances
ont lieu alors excusez-moi de vous leur
avait imposé un lieu comment ça s'est
passé non en fait avant nous c'est la
seule chose qu'on qu'on impose c'est
qu'il y ait la mention du château et qui
est que ce soit construit avec le
château et on avait l'exposition
hyacinthe rigaud le portrait soleil en a
qu'on a pu ouvrir quelques semaines
louis avec tirer les bonnes leçons qui
n'en profite non tout ça voilà ma
séparation exactement mais liront thiès
intrigue au pardon n'a pas duré
suffisamment enfin n'a pas eu sa vraie
vie non on n'a pas eu sa vraie vie après
nous on a créé des médiations à distance
qui permettait un peu de couvrir cette
période de l'acier de confinement voilà
avec l'idée de travailler sur la
représentation du pouvoir et on a
travaillé avec les artistes sur le lieu
d'exposition d'accord à savoir cette
fameuse d'orangerie de jussieu mais
c'est vrai qu'en fait ça s'est passé
peut-être un peu à l'envers des d'autres
projets dont on tond que tu as réalisé
précédemment puisque finalement les
ateliers ont eu lieu plus tôt en amont
de la médiation qui est intervenue après
c'est aussi dû au confinement et au
fermeté à la fermeture du château parce
qu'il a quand même été fermés comment
tout l'hiver
mais il nous du coup on a dû on a eu la
chance de pouvoir bénéficier de locaux
formidable au centre hospitalier de
vivre et la voilà et qui ont été
réinstallés grâce à l'offre falret à la
bourgogne qu'est ce que c'est que
l'oeuvre fallait finalement c'est quand
même le troisième partenaire du projet
qu'on a mené qui aboutit et l'exposition
d'aujourd'hui qui est une c'est une
scène elle gère un ensemble de
structures qui proposent des solutions
d'hébergement d'accueil d'accompagnement
à des personnes ayant des handicaps
psychiques souffrant de maladies
psychiques c'est exactement dans la
continuité de nos projets elle vous
envoie des malades par exemple
nous envoie pas des malades c'est à dire
quand on gère on s'occupe de personnes
qui viennent dans nos ateliers ou qui
participent à des activités artistiques
la plupart du temps
autour des arts visuels et là en
l'occurrence ils sont venus
accueillis par charles édouard de survie
des vegf les divertissements on parlera
après qu'ils ont été lésés les chefs
d'orchestre en fait de ces ateliers qui
ont lieu dans nos bureaux à plaisir donc
en fait il y avait ces personnes qui
étaient suivis par les structures
d'accord de l'oeuvre ferait
principalement et du centre en skate
plaisir aussi très bien alors donc le
prof de cette exposition c'est donc un
travail collectif entre des artistes
professionnels
contemporain confirmées à savoir charles
édouard de surville et virginie sf oui
voilà qui ont
accompagné donc des malades psychiques
pour ses créations d'oeuvres il ya
quatre oeuvres je crois principal que
l'on va voir dans cette exposition alors
je sens que vous avez envie de dire un
truc mais
déjà on va parler deux secondes des fois
pas de doute pourquoi pas plus des
artistes charles édouard de surville
alors vous pouvez m'en parlait alors
charles édouard c'est un artiste qui est
très intéressé par le ce on parle
l'interaction du son par rapport à son
environnement le 1
au départ c'est un c'est un musicien et
qui finalement à une carrière qui a été
un peu particulière qui ce qui était
plus dans la production au début et qui
depuis quelques années
participent à des créations
sonores pendant dans des lieux publics a
beaucoup travaillé que le théâtre des
amandiers c'est là justement je crois
qu'ils attendent en cela qu'il a
remporté via sa qui a déjà trois quatre
ans d'accord et elle alors ça quel est
son domaine elle assure l esstic plus
dans les arts plastiques arts visuels
mais elle s'intéresse aussi à la vidéo
et au son île la plupart de ses oeuvres
on pourrait dire sont habitées soit par
l'image 3par par le sont elles
toujours à la recherche de l'étrange de
l'incongru d'inattendu donc ils sont
bien rencontrés sur un terrain qui
n'était pas toujours très
évident a raconté je pense que c'était
on a été on a toujours été surpris
agréablement surpris enfin moi c'était
mon sentiment tout au long de ce projet
et ils ont toujours su rebondir et en
plus ce que j'ai trouvé très intéressant
dans leur démarche commune c'est qu'ils
avaient cette volonté d'intégrer à
chaque étape de ce projet les personnes
qui participaient aux ateliers en fait
le projet ils ont construit alors en
leur demandant à chacun au début mon de
comprendre ce que c'était que le son à
travers des notes qui leur donnait à
disposition avec des tablettes via génie
c'était se réaliser des maquettes en
leur expliquant on s'allie à des formes
actives - ils sont tous avec des gros
cutter d'ici enfin c'est devenu de plus
en plus gros
plus en plus ambitieux mais ils ont
participé à toutes les étapes du projet
ce qui veut dire que chaque personne
chaque personne qui a participé à la
création peut retrouver un petit morceau
de son oeuvre ou reconnaître ce qu'il a
fait et où tout est vraiment collectif
collectif il peut il peut retrouver une
femme fera une phrase musicale une
boucle un petit morceau tout bug ça
donne sa maquette qui a été mise aller à
l'échelle certaines maquettes ont été
mises à l'échelle avec la participation
de certains d'entre eux mais pas tous
parce que c'est ma contre des maquettes
qui font 20 cm de côté des maquettes qui
en trois matches bédard est c'est donc
c'est devenu quelque chose d'assez
colossal
corps et ça c'est vous avec les deux
artistes qui l'avait complètement
scénographié mis en place où les
personnels du château à participer on a
participé effectivement et en
particulier les jardiniers à leur
trianon et bien c'est virginie yassef
qui en fait a eu envie de créer un
paysage exotique pour accompagner ses
oeuvres en fait l'année dernière on a eu
un parterre africains au niveau de
trianon et donc on avait des oeuvres un
petit peu exotique des arbres à tomates
des cactus voilà donc on a travaillé
toute la journée vendredi avec les
jardiniers où ils ont ramené des des
arbres pour compléter en fait ce paysage
d'accord alors en quelques mots d'un
commun accord c'est une exposition qui
forcément aller voir ce que c'est un
univers hors du commun est
vraiment inattendu surprenant qui
correspond un peu à l'ambiance j'imagine
de 7,2 cette serre l'orangerie qui était
faite au départ souris 15 pour
accueillir des des plantes venues
d'ailleurs exotiques et surprenante
après donc c'est un peu la fin de
l'émission comment comment décrire cette
exposition vous êtes vous m'expliquer le
roi l'a évidemment n'a pas de photos ça
pas encore sûrs
cette exposition un tel désastre de
drôles d'instruments de musique
à les monolithes oui c'est ça des
oeuvres sonores qui sont assez
intéressante parce qu'elles sont toutes
animées elle se répondent toutes les
unes aux autres il ya aussi une vidéo
que je trouve particulièrement
intéressante parce qu'elle a été le
témoin de tout ce qui s'est passé et
l'artiste a réussi anatole abitbol a
réussi à capter des moments je crois
s'est agacé on a vu des images mais
c'est des moments qu'on verra en entier
pardon je vous courent à la foire de
l'expo exactement qu'est ce qui fait
qu'il est une des quatre installations
qu'il présentait est-ce que c'est pas
une vidéo c'est pas un documentaire mais
justement il a essayé de montrer
justement ses mains qu'on retrouve sur
la fiche d'accord qui finalement était
le point de seul point découvert est
commun à tous aussi d'un point de vue
physique pendant tout qu'il a tout les
toute la durée des ateliers puisqu'ils
vous rappelez quand même qu'on a été
masquée au fusain non savez-vous des
commissions cet été vous vous en êtes
très bon je trouve voilà un très gros
temps
donc c'est un magnifique projet qu'on
encourage tout le monde à aller voir on
va profiter de l'été indien pour aller
se promener du côté du trianon et de
l'orangerie du cieux c'est le du mardi
au dimanche de 12 à 19 heures si je me
trompe à 18h 18h30 voilà et la suite ce
sera un catalogue comme ça et une expo
en plus ou pas oui oui mais quand parce
que grâce à cette ode versailles a
préservé on va pouvoir avoir une
itinérance de l'exposition enfin
d'accord vous artistes aussi qui va être
qui va être exploser donc dans le
nouveau bâtiment de la fondation falret
à pantin qui est un bâtiment de 6000 m²
eux
très beau bâtiment réhabilité et dans un
atrium va pouvoir retrouver en fait
beaucoup des oeuvres de l'exposition qui
vont être scénographié à nouveau à
l'occasion de la remise du catalogue
hockey enfin c'est pas une raison pour
ne pas aller là lors du mois de
septembre il faut y aller on va y aller
on y sera stéphanie de la fosse merci
beaucoup leur hausse du pain merci
beaucoup bravo conseiller belle énergie
créative et artistique et à très bientôt
j'espère oui merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi et à très vite ans
[Musique]